you're donating some of your time for a
good cause it's actually a cause is this
right that your mom started called all
it takes is that right
it is we started it together 10 years
ago and then I was just like mom I don't
have the bandwidth to really funnel all
of my energy into this so she took it
over and she's doing an amazing work I
mean right now specifically they've
created a program because there's so
many people at home dealing with anxiety
and it's kind of this weird thing that
we're not talking about a lot I feel
like when it comes to kovat but people
are home they don't know when they're
gonna work again kids have parents
teaching them homework that parents
don't you know they don't know what
they're doing and suicide rates are up
and depression is up and people just
don't have tools to cope and so there's
a program online that she's grated every
Sunday and then multiple times
throughout the month they go on and have
these panels and discussions on how you
can cope with the anxiety that you're
experiencing at home what no matter what
age you're at I think that's a really
good point because my experience has
been people think if you're just staying
in your home you almost don't have the
right to be anxious and there's a lot of
people saying they do that well there's
real people out there on the frontlines
and the hospital worker is they deserve
to be anxious but not me because I'm at
home eating a burrito and binge watching
you know some TV show when the point is
there's a lot of anxiety out there oh
I mean imagine how many people I don't
know if they're ever gonna work again
who have been laid off because they
weren't in the top one-third of their
company's employees and there's there's
so much uncertainty and I think our in
our country too we we don't really have
we didn't have any way to prepare for
this so yeah resources for anxiety are
major and and may is the Mental Health
Awareness Month so yeah it is true
[Laughter]